[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 23 novembre
voici les titres le début de la 37e
campagne d'hiver des restos du coeur
nous serons centre de plaisir qui a
accueilli ce matin ses premiers
bénéficiaires alors nombre devrait
encore augmenter cette année avec une
pauvreté qui s'aggrave en france invités
de cette édition fabienne lambert vice
présidente des restos du coeur des
yvelines le congrès les républicains
pour désigner le candidat du parti à
l'élection présidentielle approche en
lice notamment philippe juvin le maire
de la garenne colombes était en meeting
hier à plaisir environ quarante
militants sont venus écouter ses
propositions et puis c'est une nécessité
il devra subir des travaux pour
continuer sa vocation accueillir des
enfants hospitalisés
le centre pédiatrique des côtes va
bénéficier de l'exposition du loto du
patrimoine aux loges en josas est la
collecte visant à récolter des fonds
pour la rénovation vient de débuter dans
ce journal également un composteur un
électro composteur même installé à
villepreux on vous explique tout dans un
instant
est la 37e campagne d'hiver tout d'abord
des restos du coeur je vous en parlais
dans les titres qui s'est ouverte donc
ce mardi partout en france on en parle
avec mon invité fabienne lambert bonsoir
vous êtes la vice présidente de
l'association départementale des restos
du coeur les restos du coeur des
yvelines avant de parler de cette
campagne d'hiver qui s'ouvre avec vous
direction plaisir ou l'antenne locale
accueille 180 familles en ce début de
campagne ces derniers mois est de
nouveaux profils sont apparues avec la
crise sanitaire et la crise du pouvoir
d'achat le reportage de michael et demi
d'euros
c'est mardi 23 novembre l'antenne locale
des restos du coeur de plaisir a rouvert
ses portes pour sa campagne hivernale la
situation
je suis avec ma fille j'ai lu resto mais
au delà nous restons mais donne des
aides ont vu la rue mais si chaque
moment me l'a dit mais si la situation
de cette plaisir oise n'est pas un cas
isolé de nombreuses mères célibataires
sont présentes dans les files d'attentes
de cette antenne yvelinoise avec la
crise sanitaire et la crise du pouvoir
d'achat le centre s'attend également à
voir s'inscrire de nouvelles familles
bénéficiaires dans les prochains jours
il faut savoir que les profils qu'on a
là de la période d'yves qu'on inscrire
en été en hiver là c'est une toutes nos
familles de cet été donc si vous voulez
les nouveaux profils vont arriver un peu
plus tard avec 40 pour son augmentation
d'inscriptions depuis un an dont 2 fois
plus de bébés la cinquantaine de
bénévoles sert plusieurs milliers de
repas chaque semaine les chiffres qui
pourrait exposer cet hiver selon les
responsables du centre l'année dernière
on a fini la campagne d'hiver avec 300
familles et là on redémarre la campagne
d'hiver déjà avec 180 familles donc je
pense qu'on va avoir une progression
tout au long de l'année et qu'on finit
ce mois de mars sûrement avec plus de 3
plus de 350 familles il ya des grandes
chances en france les restos du coeur
ont servi près de 1,5 million de repas
l'hiver dernier
et je vous disais en plateau l'ia
fabienne lambert qui est avec moi vice
président des restos du coeur des
yvelines alors le constat qui est fait
dans ce reportage à plaisir ce que vous
le faites aussi au niveau départemental
avec de nouveaux profils de nouveaux
bénéficiaires on a parlé dans le
reportage notamment des familles
monoparentales qui venait de plus en
plus oui oui tout à fait on a une
recrudescence des familles
monoparentales on a eu pendant la crise
aussi une recrudescence des personnes
avec des petits travaux précaires qui
faisait à et donc qu'ils se sont trouvés
sans travail qui sont venus frapper à la
porte des restos et puis aussi des
étudiants donc justement les étudiants
on peut voir peut-être quelques images
du spot 2021 de cette campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur qui sont au coeur
les étudiants de ce spot on y voit la
précarité avec notamment un jeune
étudiant qui refusent auprès de ses
copains d'aller à une soirée d'aller à
une soirée cinéma justement parce qu'il
doit aller à la collecte des restos du
coeur est ce que la crise sanitaire a
aggravé justement ce cet état de
précarité chez les étudiants il ya plus
d'étudiants aujourd'hui plus d'étudiants
et on a même été amenés à faire des
directement voir des étudiants en bas de
l'hôtel où il y avait des étudiants du
crous pour les livrer directement
effectivement et ce sont des jeunes qui
parfois ont du mal à passer la porte
mais y'a pas que les jeunes on voit
régulièrement des gens pleurer c'est
compliqué on fait notre maximum pour les
accueillir avec bienveillance
c'est ce que pourquoi ils ont du mal
justement à passer les portes des restos
du coeur parce qu'ils ont honte y'a pas
de honte à avoir mais il pensait pas
avoir besoin un jour de venir aux restos
du coeur et c'est parfois compliqué et
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a fait ce spot
pour expliquer que vous nous pas le dire
c'est compliqué de dire qu'on a qu'on a
un souci parfois même ne serait-ce que
momentanée et donc on va se trouver un
un argument j'ai un resto mais en fait
le resto c'est d'aller au resto du coeur
dont justement l'étudiant qu'on voit
dans ce spot a toujours de petite excuse
quand ses copains lui demande de venir
avec lui avec eux en soirée combien de
bénéficiaires sur la campagne d'hiver de
l'an passé combien y at il eu de
bénéficiaires sur l'ensemble de l'année
on a eu à peu près quinze mille
bénéficiaires et on a distribué à peu
près deux millions de repas et on a
observé sur cette période d'été environ
10 % d'inscrits en plus donc ça veut
dire que les projections pour la
campagne qui arrivent elles sont elles
sont à la hausse vous pensez que vous
allez avoir encore plus de bénéficiaires
oui et on pense qu'on va avoir encore
plus de bénéficiaires liée à la
précarité est aussi un effet qui est
liée notamment à la hausse de tout ce
qui est énergique ou d énergie qui doit
pas forcément maintenant parce que des
fois les factures elles arrivent au mois
de janvier de février sachant que
souvent les personnes précaires sans
plus dans dés peuvent être dans des
passoires thermiques dans des logements
mal isolés donc avec un coût de
l'énergie qui peut fortement augmenté
donc avec le peut-être des effets qui
peuvent se répercuter vous verrez les
conséquences dans quelques mois un effet
crise sanitaire aussi on peut l'imaginer
qui a peut-être davantage aggraver la
précarité à peu près la moitié des gens
nous disent que leur situation s'est
aggravée pendant la crise sanitaire et
il ya à peu près on steam 10-15 % des
gens qui viendraient aux restos du coeur
qui ne serait peut-être pas venu s'il
n'y avait pas eu la crise sanitaire qui
a créé aussi forcément l'imaginent de
l'isolément aussi pour ces personnes de
l isolement tout à fait de l' isolement
et parfois un sentiment de honte parce
que c'est tout est arrivé en fait
rapidement comme une baffe alors la
mobilisation des restos du coeur des
civils pendant cette campagne d'hiver 27
centres de distribution c'est ça dans
les airs line up des singes et pas j'ai
pas les brochets dans 22 centres voilà
plus de centres des 22 centres est ce qu
il y aura des actions peut être éphémère
de deux centres justement éphémère dans
des zones rurales je ne sais pas alors
nous sommes en train de travailler en
fait et j'ai une réunion jeudi pour
essayer de développer en fait des
camions qui iraient directement au pied
de certains endroits discrètement parce
que les gens tiennent à ce que soient
discrets pour livrer la nourriture au
plus près des personnes qu'on travaille
effectivement sur le sujet ça nos
projets de l'année et notre autre projet
c'est de développer tout ce qui aide à
la personne alors forcément on pense à
l'aide alimentaire vous parlez aussi de
l'aide à la personne qu'il ya d'autres
vocations aussi pour les restos du coeur
pendant cette campagne oui tout à fait
donc là la chose donc on connaît restos
du coeur qu'on pense tout de suite à
d'alimentaire mais ça s'appelle aussi
les relais du coeur et les relais du
coeur en fait on veut parler de l'aide à
la personne du club de la personne c'est
s'assurer que les gens leurs droits en
termes de santé leurs droits sociaux on
va donner aussi des cours de français on
va faire du soutien leur recherche
d'emploi on va faire du microcrédit en
fait notre idée à nous c'est
d'accompagner les gens la meilleure
chose mieux chouette aux perceuses et
qu'on accueille ses dires moi je serais
ravi de ne pas vous revoir dans un
centre restos du coeur mais de vous
revoir plutôt à plus tard avec une
situation est pleinement heureux vous
vous croisez dans la rue pleinement
heureux mais pour restos du coeur et
c'est une autre des restos du coeur bien
sûr qu'ils y est aussi possible grâce
aux bénévoles à l'apport des bénévoles
combien de bénévoles dans les yvelines
alors nous sommes près de 1000 bénévoles
nous cherchons toujours de nouveaux
bénévoles notamment pour développer
toute cette aide
la personne et puis nous cherchons aussi
des bénévoles parce que en mars on va
voir la collecte donc il faut pas
hésiter à venir se porte à peine la
porte et puis il ya cette chose qu'on
connaît moins des restos du coeur ont
parlé des relais du coeur et on peut
venir se faire aider sur la dda
personnes sans monde est forcément de
l'aide alimentaire voilà c'est ouvert à
tout le monde alors justement le l'appel
qu'on peut lancer pour les
téléspectateurs qui nous regardent si
pour aider les restos du coeur on peut
devenir soit bénévole peut-être faire
des dons aussi pour pour aider
l'association à fait on peut faire des
dons nous avons des chantiers
d'insertion donc on peut nous amener son
vieil ordinateur on peut organiser des
collectes
voilà et puis faire des dons passer du
temps de façon régulière quentin
bénévoles réguliers ou bénévoles
occasionnels et on trouve bien sûr
toutes les informations sur le site de
l'association départementale est des
restos du coeur qui est affichée en bas
de l'écran merci à vous fabienne lambert
d'être passé en plateau et je rappelle
que vous êtes la vice présidente des
restos du coeur des yvelines
[Musique]
dans l'actualité également la
mobilisation d'une trentaine de
personnes ce mardi à guyancourt ces
soignants de la page yvelines se sont
réunis devant le siège de l'association
qui accompagne tous les types de
handicaps des employés en grève dans les
quatre foyers du département à magny les
hameaux elancourt aubergenville et en
brésil dénoncent une surcharge de
travail engendrée par un manque de
personnel avec de nombreuses démissions
depuis deux ans et soignants demande
également une revalorisation salariale
hausse prévue normalement par le ségur 2
de la santé qui s'élargit est depuis le
1er octobre à 9000 soignants dans le
secteur privé du médico social non
entendus par leur direction les
personnes mobilisées entendent continuer
la grève et dans dix jours les 148 mille
adhérents du parti les républicains
devront voter en ligne pour leur
candidat qui les représentera à
l'élection présidentielle en lice
notamment philippe juvin qui s'est donc
rendu à la salle des faits des gâtines à
plaisir ce lundi pour rencontrer les
électeurs et exposer ses idées chez
mathilde franco
maire de la garenne colombes dans les
hauts-de-seine philippe juvin c'est
qu'il n'est pas parmi les favoris le
candidat au congrès les républicains
souhaitent tout de même faire entendre
ses idées dans cette campagne ce lundi
22 novembre il est venu échanger avec
une quarantaine de militants dans la
salle des fêtes des gâtines à plaisir
je continue à travailler en ayant des
bandages à la fois un homme politique
réelle j'ai même été dix ans député
européen et en même temps j'ai toujours
un métier j'ai des expériences qui me
permettent de savoir prendre des
décisions difficiles dans la salle une
quarantaine de militants pour certains
toujours indécis je suis venu parce que
j'aimerais entendre toutes les
propositions des différents candidats
c'est un homme de conviction c'est un an
clientes et qui tiendra ses paroles je
pense ce matin je l'écouté sur bfm déjà
il se dit qu'on lui parle chef des
urgences de l'hôpital georges-pompidou
les services publics lui tiennent à
coeur ils nagent à contre-courant sur la
question des fonctionnaires selon lui il
ne faut pas réduire le nombre d'emplois
mais redistribuer les rôles en diminuant
les postes administratifs et en
augmentant les postes en contact avec le
public je pense que la droite
doit être une droite qui réfléchit à des
questions qui ne sont pas les siennes
habituellement la question des services
publics moi je suis pour la droite des
services publics je pense que les
services publics c'est indispensable
à ce que tout le monde soit pareillement
traité sur le territoire et parce que
c'est un élément de prospérité quand
vous avez l'école qui fonctionne vous
avez des ingénieurs et des scientifiques
d'un temps plus tard face à philippe
juvin quatre autres candidats michel
barnier xavier bertrand eric ciotti et
valérie pécresse on est honnêtement dans
un flou artistique chez nous et l'air
parce qu'on n'a pas encore de candidat
mais quand la dynamique va être lancé je
pense qu'on va retrouver notre électorat
qui nous a fait gagner jusqu'à
maintenant les adhérents du parti les
républicains devront départager les cinq
candidats lors d'un congrès en ligne du
1er au 4 décembre
en pleine semaine de réduction des
déchets villepreux inauguré son électro
composteur il est installé à la cuisine
centrale du groupe scolaire jean de la
fontaine il va à collecter et traiter
les biodéchets des cinq écoles de la
commune et de plus d'un millier
d'habitants l'objectif c'est de
respecter la directive européenne qui va
entrer en vigueur à partir du 31
décembre 2023 le reportage de céline
charles et de mélanie poquet
financé par la région et l'agglomération
l'électro composteur de villepreux et
qu'une solution complète de traitement
de gestion des biodéchets écologique et
économique ce composteur de taille
intermédiaire peu contenir jusqu'à 160
kg de déchets par jour le composteur
électronique à l'iccat cycl c'est le
moyen de composter localement les
déchets sans nuisance est au plus près
des sites émetteurs donc les écoles les
habitants ne peut pas sur des quantités
de bio déchets fermentescibles comme ça
restait sur le compostage classique
manuel on a besoin d'avoir une
manipulation importante donc qui ne peut
être que mécanique on a besoin de remuer
régulièrement pour que ça fonctionne en
quinze jours on a besoin de monter en
température on a besoin de monter à 60
70 degrés donc effectivement la solution
et électromécaniques et la sole qui
correspondent à l'enjeu communal qu'on
s'est dit les circuits courts aussi sur
la thématique de la gestion des déchets
c'est à dire des déchets qui vont
directement de l'assiette au traitement
sans passer par un autre site on est
quelque chose de totalement vertueux
écologiquement parlant des déchets qui
seront récoltés depuis les points
d'apport volontaire à l'aide d'un vélo
électrique avec remorque le compost
obtenu à la fin sera redistribué dans
les espaces verts de la ville et les
jardins partagés par des enjeux de ce
système ces deux d'éviter encore de le
diminuer les nuisances donc on va
remplacer le camion poubelle par un vélo
cargo électrique donc les opérateurs de
la cantine de la cuisine centrale vont
venir collecter les différentes écoles
mais aussi les points d'apport
volontaire en vélo et on va voir du
compost qui va être redistribué à donner
à des associations locales notamment
pour les jardins partagés pour les
jardins solidaires on a aussi nos
services techniques qui vont pouvoir
utiliser ce compost pour leur travail du
quotidien pour des plantations une
action qui a comme objectif à terme de
se développer dans d'autres
collectivités trappe devrait poursuivre
l'expérimentation dans quelques mois
suivi de près par voisins le bretonneux
le site installé aux loges en josas a
été retenu par le loto du patrimoine
2021 le centre pédiatrique déco doit
réaliser de nombreux travaux pour
continuer à accueillir des enfants
hospitalisés ce lundi une collecte était
officiellement lancée avec la fondation
du patrimoine pour récolter des fonds en
vue de la rénovation justin brasier et
célia 400 go le centre pédiatrique des
codes doit être restaurée implanté
depuis 1952 aux loges en josas dans un
château du 19 yem siècle le centre prend
en charge de jeunes patients atteints de
maladies cardiaques respiratoires ou
encore digestives aujourd'hui
d'importants travaux doivent être
effectués le zinc de la toiture du
château et a changé
ce sont des châteaux qui avait un style
très particulier un petit peu moyenâgeux
avec des grandes des guides et des
tourelles et des grandes cheminées donc
on a les cheminées qui fissure avec des
risques d'effondrement tout simplement
de la cheminée ou des tourelles et puis
et puis les terrasses des terres des
toits terrasses qui vous font refaire
tout l'étanchéité en fait du toit une
rénovation estimés à 600 mille euros le
centre a fait appel à la fondation du
patrimoine pour l'assister dans la
recherche de fonds un dossier qui a
retenu l'attention pour son intérêt
patrimonial et architectural
l'autre partie c'est un projet
intéressant parce qu'il représente c'est
à dire le travail de l'hôpital
destiné aux enfants
voyant des malformations cardiaques et c
est un sujet tout à fait important et
sensibilisateurs pour nous et on est on
pense effectivement que l'ensemble c'est
à dire patrimoniale plus sociale
constitue un dossier dynamique un
dossier qui peut avoir un véritable
succès la collecte était officiellement
lancé lundi 22 novembre pour participer
rendez vous sur le site de la fondation
anniversaires mariages événements en
tous genres les occasions ne manquent
pas pour fêter autour d'un gâteau est
depuis quelques années la tendance est
au dessert personnalisés réalisés sur
mesure est parfait pour vos clichés sur
les réseaux sociaux à mézy-sur-seine une
pâtissière s'est lancé dans le cac
design rencontre signée coeliaque à 200
go
[Musique]
sauvegarde à une petite particularité
c'est que j'ai ouvert complètement
l'intérieur et j'ai glissé des petits
mnm ce don quand on va le coupé il y
aura une petite cascade de menace à
l'intérieur ce sera la surprise pour les
enfants et chapuis pâtissière diplômée
depuis l'an dernier élabore la dernière
étape de slayer cake la décoration sur
un thème original le dessin animé là pas
de patrouille tous les personnages sont
en pâte à sucre on me demande pas mal
des thèmes jungle forêt
j'ai déjà eu
qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres un petit
renard un animal une baleine ce genre de
choses si rennes aussi c'est un gros en
ce moment où nous demande beaucoup de
sirène cela fait un mois que cette
pâtissière vient d'obtenir son tout
nouveau laboratoire de pâtisserie basée
à mézy-sur-seine ici elle réalise des
cakes design des gâteaux personnaliser
selon vos envies
un des derniers foyers demandé c'était
un peu le thème gatsby dont vous n'avez
pas trop de pas trop d'infos autre que
du blanc du or un peu les années folles
donc donc c'est plutôt chouette moi
j'aime bien comment je sais c'est
toujours un challenge à ce genre de
choses parce que parce que ça fait un
peu travaillé mon imagination alors je
regarde beaucoup je je je je regarde un
peu sur internet je regarde un peu
à quoi ça ressemblait pied de la jeu de
la jauge et des idées qui viennent un
layer cake se fait en plusieurs étapes
puisqu'il y a des grands en offrait tout
est fait maison génoise crème ou encore
coulis on peut tout imaginer dedans il
faut compter 6 euros 50 minimum la part
pour un gâteau classique moi ce que
j'aime dans ce que je fais c'est
vraiment créer inventer c'est à dire ne
pas juste faire de la pâtisserie
traditionnelle parce qu'elle se fait
très très bien dans beaucoup de
pâtisseries mais c'est vraiment créer
quelque chose d'un peu grandiose et qui
remet un peu plein la vue aux gens la
pâtissière fait également des pièces
montées ou encore des sweats 'table elle
réalise sur une table le goûter en
entier avec des capex des cookies ou
encore des nains bertic
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité une édition de vous
retrouver bien sûr en replay nous sommes
désolés pour les quelques soucis à
techniques qui nous ont fait perdre le
direct au cours de ce journal vous
retrouverez bien sûr à sur notre site
internet notre application mobile le
journal en entier on parlait notamment
en début de journal de l'ouverture
aujourd'hui de la 37e campagne d'hiver
des restos du coeur dans un instant
rester avec nous le 7-8 culture sur tv
78 à partir de 18h30 et célia agathe son
go parlera notamment et du festival
escales urbaines qui se tient à plaisir
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]